hi it's Michelle of loudmouth and Beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
big fan of sunscreen not such a fan of
sunscreen myths it's summer for almost
everyone but Australians so everyone is
talking about sunscreens I've debunked a
lot of myths about sunscreen before
things like sunscreens are toxic you can
make your own sunscreen safely but today
I'm going to be focusing on incorrect
advice from trusted media sources
because you would expect them to be
correct and these myths are a bit harder
to spot and they have less obvious but
still bad consequences I'm going to go
through a bunch of sunscreen news
articles explain what they got wrong and
what you should be doing instead I don't
entirely blame the people writing these
articles because this is part of a
larger problem with sunscreen
misinformation from trusted sources
which we will see hopefully this will be
an interesting Excursion like And
subscribe for more nerdy Beauty content
we're going to start with this article
from USA Today called what is mineral
sunscreen and why you may want to use it
instead of chemical sunscreen I'm trying
not to have a reaction just to this
headline because a lot of sunscreen
myths end up supporting this idea that
mineral sunscreens are better and safer
which is mostly just confirmation bias
for people's gut feelings that natural
things should be safer and better this
isn't true this is just a gut feeling
that we've evolved because back in the
day we would go into the wild and if we
saw something weird it was probably
going to be dangerous but these days we
have much better ways of working out
which things are dangerous versus safe
we don't have to rely on this gut
feeling which just doesn't really work
in our modern world but I guess
technically this headline is fair
because mineral sunscreen is a better
option for some people just not as many
as the media and social media tends to
make it out to be for most people
chemical sunscreens are going to be a
better option and they actually do say
the reasons why so they say there is
ease of application and aesthetic appeal
and these two things are really
underrated mineral sunscreen gives a
white cast on lots of people's skin
especially if you are darker skinned it
also tends to feel thicker and less
comfortable so that means a lot of
people don't apply enough or they just
skip applying it all together which is a
much worse situation than using a
chemical sunscreen there are currently
14 FDA approved chemical filters in the
US but many more overseas chemical
sunscreens have very small amounts of
systemic absorption into one's
bloodstream so systemic means it goes
into your body and goes everywhere so it
could potentially affect parts of your
body not just your skin this finding has
drawn lots of attention however at this
time it is not known that this Trace
amount is problematic this is a pretty
good summary of those FDA studies that
came out in 2019 and 2020 I would have
preferred if she also mentioned where
the current evidence is pointing so for
example in the EU this absorption has
been known for quite a long time and so
they've always assessed the safety of
sunscreens based on that for like almost
20 years I go into a lot more detail
about the evidence in my US versus EU
sunscreens video basically the EU has
been reaval evaluating a lot of these
older more controversial chemical
sunscreens and there is still a really
large margin of safety she has
additionally if one has really sensitive
skin chemical sunscreens are more likely
to cause a reaction this is true on
average for U.S sunscreens but on an
individual level this is not necessarily
true in Europe for example mineral-only
sunscreens aren't really a thing all
their sensitive skin sunscreens have
lots of chemical filters because they
tend to be better at blocking UV they
tend to use the newer chemical filters
that don't get into the skin as easily
to cause irritation and so overall you
end up with more protection against both
irritants as well as the sun there's
also this issue with SPF boosters which
are these chemical sunscreen like
ingredients that are not strictly
regulated as chemical sunscreens but
they have very similar structures and
very similar properties these are listed
as inactive ingredients rather than
active ingredients and so people aren't
looking out for them and they end up
reacting and they just don't know why
Newsome says mineral sunscreen could be
referred to as physical sunscreen
because it's a physical blocker they're
really really good because they reflect
the UV rather than the chemical
sunscreen that absorbs the UV this is
the most common myth in all the
sunscreen articles I've read it is like
the origin of a whole bunch of myths for
why mineral sunscreens are better I made
this family tree a while ago showing how
this has birthed so many myths so what's
been known for a really long time more
than 50 years that mineral sunscreens
also mostly absorb UV only about five to
ten percent is reflected this is because
these mineral sunscreens have a
semiconductor structure I've talked
about it before in my video on how
sunscreens work one of the big reasons
this myth is still around is because the
American Academy of Dermatology website
still has this there's an art Hill in
2016 that re-demonstrated that this is
true for sunscreen specifically but yeah
it's just still around this is one of
those issues where you would think you
would be able to trust a source but this
is not their specialty my best advice
for working out what is and isn't true
is to look for the consensus of relevant
experts for how sunscreens interact with
UV this is chemistry or physics it isn't
Dermatology and so those are the more
relevant experts and the consensus is
overwhelmingly that they work by
absorption so there isn't much of a
difference they're not going to be
really really good because they reflect
this extra five percent it isn't really
reflected this five to ten percent is
actually scattered and most of that UV
gets scattered towards the skin deeper
in to that sunscreen layer most of the
time it'll hit another molecule and get
absorbed which is what we want
absorption is better because it actually
takes the UV and turns it into something
else usually mostly heat the scattering
just kind of bounces the UV somewhere
else and lets someone else deal with it
Newsome says mineral sunscreen is a
little bit more effective than chemical
sunscreen they have a little bit broader
spectrum of coverage if you look at zinc
oxide it does look like it has a pretty
flat spec term it covers a lot of
wavelengths on its own but if you take
chemical sunscreens and put them
together they cover the same wavelengths
and usually they can get much higher
protection so it doesn't really matter
that zinc oxide on its own can cover
everything because when you buy a
sunscreen you're not buying individual
chemical filters this is a problem that
is solved by the people formulating the
sunscreen we don't have to worry about
this we just buy the one sunscreen so
we're looking for a high SPF rating and
the words broad spectrum or a high PPD
or PA rating that's what these are there
for these directly measure what sort of
protection you're getting from the
product the article mentions the issues
with the application and Aesthetics
people are less likely to apply the
appropriate amount due to the thicker
opaque nature of these formulations
completely true this is a huge problem
however in recent years mineral
sunscreens have come a long way and
there are now numerous products with a
lightweight field that apply with ease
this is true but a lot of the time they
are still relying on those SPF boosters
which are really just chemical sunscreen
so really they are hybrid sunscreens
pretending to be mineral sunscreens
which is kind of just false advertising
that I'm not really comfortable with
next I mentioned that there are tinted
mineral sunscreens which just basically
takes the white cast out of it which
isn't entirely true that ycast is still
often there and sometimes the tint is
also not quite the right color for your
face so it's kind of like I guess
two bad things that still end up making
one bad thing but I think looking for a
tinted mineral sunscreen is still pretty
good advice this next bit though
chemical sunscreens have also been
implicated in harming marine life in the
ocean Newsome says you can avoid this by
using mineral sunscreens as they are
very safe there is this really common
myth that chemical sunscreens and Nano
mineral sunscreens are bad for mirroring
life but non-nano mineral sunscreen is
completely safe this is based on this
2016 study by Craig downs and co-workers
the scientists who did this study
promoted really aggressively in the
media on the day of release which is
pretty unusual I've explained this a bit
more in my video on resale sunscreens as
well as in my environmental myths video
last year the national academies did a
review of all of the evidence and their
conclusion is mineral and chemical
sunscreens overlap in regard to
environmental impact but overall it
doesn't seem like sunscreen has much of
an impact at all because they are
massively diluted the amounts in the
ocean are so tiny and the effect I can
have is really really small compared to
things like global warming and
agricultural runoff and land use and
overfishing that down study was a
massive outlier there were lots of
issues with how they conducted their
experiments this article links to an
NOAA page called Skin Care chemicals and
coral reefs which is another example of
a source you thought you could trust
this page has kind of been haunting me
for a few years because people would
always bring it up in arguments to say
the NOAA obviously knows more about
coral than you do so it's worth
mentioning that in the National
academies report which was written by a
lot of Choral experts who actually did
the original studies specifically
references this page alongside the ewg
and a bunch of other questionable Pages
as examples of misinformation the page
says NOA is reviewing the National
Academy study and upon completion of
this review they will update the
information presented in this article as
warranted that was done in August 2022
clearly there are still media articles
relying on it so it would be nice if
they updated it onto our next article
this is from NPR and it's called picking
the right sunscreen isn't as important
as avoiding these six mistakes so I
quite like the overall message of this
headline because there aren't that many
differences between sunscreens I do
think people tend to over focus on
things like mineral versus chemical
really over analyzing their sunscreens
really the best thing to do is to pick a
sunscreen that you like and apply a lot
of it so they start by telling you to
check out last year's sunscreen which I
think is pretty good advice if your
sunscreen has been in last year's pool
bag it's probably been sitting around in
the Heat and heat is bad for sunscreens
sunscreens are emulsions that means they
are blends of water and oil-based
ingredients which are not happy together
they're held in place temporarily by
emulsifiers but eventually they want to
separate if you have heat that gives
them enough energy to start separating
faster sometimes when you squirt out an
old sunscreen you'll see that it has
separated and that means it's not going
to apply on on your skin the same way so
the advice is good but the reason is not
as good they say the active compounds
can degrade and lose their effectiveness
this is true but most of the time it is
the separation and this does contribute
to the idea that mineral sunscreens are
more stable which is not really true
because those minerals are quite dense
they want to settle to the bottom but
they don't quite say that so I'm going
to leave that as half a myth in my
rather subjective scoring system so the
first mistake they list is concerned
about chemicals try a mineral
alternative I don't like the way they've
worded this because they are just kind
of accepting the premise that chemicals
are something to be concerned about even
though of course mineral sunscreens
contain chemicals everything is
chemicals but also chemical sunscreen
specifically are meant to be something
to be concerned about so they sum up the
situation with the FDA and they say
there's no evidence of harm but then
they end with still if you're concerned
there are options to avoid these
compounds I do like that they're
highlighting there are options if you
are concerned but they're kind of both
sizing this as a media Outlet I think
their role is to get to the truth show
the scientific consensus which is they
are safe and the FDA actually has a quiz
on their site one of the questions is
actually a recent FDA study showed that
some sunscreen ingredients are absorbed
into the body and they give you four
options for what you should do the
correct option is I should continue to
use sunscreen as directed evidence of
assortion doesn't mean these ingredients
aren't safe it just means more data is
needed at the time those studies were
published the FDA also said you didn't
have to avoid particular ingredients so
as expected they have the whole thing
about physical sunscreens physically
blocking UV light which is not true but
then they add that zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide are much safer than
chemical sunscreens because they're so
inert inert means that they don't react
but that's not why they're safer they're
safer because their particles are huge
and can't get through the skin very far
this is actually how the newer chemical
sunscreens are designed zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide are not inertia a lot
of the time they get coated before they
get put into a sunscreen to make like a
physical barrier between those particles
and the rest of the sunscreen because
they mess up the formulation and this
inert concept is linked to the idea that
chemical sunscreens have to react with
skin to work NPR has that in another
sunscreen article that's linked from
this article this leads to other myths
like chemical sunscreens take 20 minutes
to work or they have to be applied to
bare skin both of which are not true
they work immediately you can put some
chemical sunscreen on a piece of paper
shine a UV light on it and you can see
that it is blocking the UV they make
some points about why mineral sunscreens
are better they're less likely to
irritate which I guess is fair and there
are newer ones which are more
cosmetically elegant again I think
that's fair but this one unlike chemical
sunscreens these mineral based Sun
blocks can stay on the surface of skin
and act as a shield or barrier to
deflect sunlight chemical sunscreens
also almost completely stay on the
surface they don't go past the top few
layers of skin which are dead except in
tiny quantities again I think this comes
from that word absorb as well as
absorbing UV people have confused that
with absorbing into skin and again we
have a link to that NOAA page on
sunscreens destroying coral reefs now
here is another myth that I see a lot a
sunscreen with an SPS Sun projection
factor of 15 blocks about 93 of UV rays
when you bump that off to SPF 30 you're
blocking about 97 higher than that
you're not getting a lot more sun
protection this is not a good way of
looking at it for a few different
reasons you can look at what gets
blocked versus what gets in so you can
say 93 versus 97 or you can say seven
percent gets in versus three percent
gets in what gets in makes more sense
because that is what impacts you it only
matters if it does and starts
interacting with stuff inside your body
that means that SPF 15 is letting in
about twice as many UV photons which
means you have double the chance of
damage the second part of this is that
97 only happens if you apply it
perfectly exactly two milligrams per
square centimeter and you apply it
perfectly evenly over your entire skin
which is not going to happen most people
don't apply enough they apply less than
half that amount which means you get
half of the Protection Plus even us
sunscreen notes are not going to apply
perfectly even to all of our skin but
when you're looking at what gets in that
still scales with protection so SPF 30
will always let in half as much UV as
SPF 15 if you apply the same amount you
will always get double the protection so
this leads into this other aspect which
is there's no point going above SPF 30
but this isn't true in practice because
of all this stuff we've just talked
about there are studies where people
applied SPF 100 or SPF 50 sunscreen
there were about half as many sunburns
with SPF 100 not just one percent less
this is actually why SPF ratings are
designed the way they are you are not
meant to overthink that number there's a
paper from some sunscreen scientists
trying to get people to stop saying this
97 thing but the AED still has it on
their website I do agree with this bit
of skimping on sunscreen is probably a
bigger mistake than not going above SPF
30 but the amounts they recommend are
not correct the recommendations for
sunscreen and mouths are based on two
milligrams per square centimeter which
is what you need to get that SPF on the
label for the average adult it's pretty
much agreed that it will be 35 mils for
your entire body there are a bunch of
papers calculating how much you should
be applying and then translating it to
rough amounts that are easy to remember
that's where all this shot glass and
teaspoon stuff comes from there's even a
paper where they suggest a beer cap now
the problem with all of these guidelines
is that they are rough and the more
people talk about them on the Internet
the more it spreads it gets rougher and
rougher on top of that there is this
sort of like Imperial versus metric
issue the size of a shot glass is not
standard around the world in Australia
it is 30 mils in the US it is 30 to 44
mils in Romania it is 100 mils so one
ounce is closer to the right amount than
1.5 ounces now for the face one of the
original papers where they suggest this
Teespring thing they actually calculated
three mils which is a bit over half a
teaspoon for the face and neck this has
been further approximated by different
places like the Australian cancer
Council they recommend one teaspoon for
face and neck and ears a lot of people
have also measured how big their face is
a quarter teaspoon for just your face is
actually a pretty generous estimate
already so one teaspoon is just too much
that is four times as much and most
people's faces don't even need that full
quarter teaspoon for my face this
teaspoon would be six and a half times
too much it just isn't really achievable
and I think when you give people such an
unachievable goal it's just really
discouraging you just end up thinking
sunscreen isn't going to work unless
it's dripping off your face and that's
not worth it so you may as well just not
bother they have some good advice here
they say spray sunscreens are risky
which is true they say SPF doesn't tell
you about time and you still need to
reapply sunscreen they have the correct
explanation for why you need to reapply
because they wear off especially if
you're swimming or sweating they
mentioned that you still can get
sunburned on a cloudy day which is true
and they say don't keep your sunscreen
in a hot place very good advice layering
sunscreen with Hats clothing and
sunglasses this is great advice I have
some videos on how to choose Sun
protective clothing and how much
protection you get with Hats they also
mentioned these UV stickers which tell
you when it's time to reapply sunscreen
which is the correct use of them I've
seen a lot of people on social media
using them to test sunscreens which
doesn't actually work it's just meant to
be a cute way of reminding you to
reapply now this next part is a bit of
an issue I've seen this in a bunch of
Articles lately it's this idea that
people with black skin still need to use
sunscreen to prevent skin cancer there's
a research dermatologist who's done a
lot of work on this topic his name is a
day Adamson he gave a talk at the
sunscreen air Summit I hosted with Jen
of the Eco well last year he has
analyzed lots of different types of data
and they all show that there is no
correlation between sun exposure and
skin cancer in black skin for example
there is no increase in skin cancer and
black skin when you go to towards the
equator now it is true that black people
do still get melanoma and not in Sun
exposed areas but it isn't because
there's less melon in there a lot of
people mentioned Bob Marley and how he
died of a melanoma under his toenail but
that was an acrome melanoma which is not
associated with sun exposure even in
white skin toenails are actually
excellent sunscreen they block all of UV
and they only let in about 0.5 to 2.5
percent of UVA there is a concern with
people with black skin they tend to have
lower skin cancer survival rates because
they tend to be detected later and this
is because of systemic issues black
people are less likely to go to the
dermatologist and melanomas don't look
the same on dark skin so a lot of
doctors can't spot them because of lack
of training so the message that black
people can still get skin cancer is
helpful but then linking it to sun
exposure linking it to not wearing
enough sunscreen is just not right this
is the wrong solution it doesn't really
help and it's sort of misallocates your
resources whether that's attention or
investment Public Health there are other
reasons for black people to wear
sunscreen it prevents wrinkles it
prevents hyperpigmentation which is how
dark skin tends to age and it prevents
sunburn but skin cancer is not a good
reason to wear it there's this
Washington Post article recently where
they had Dr Adamson talking about his
research and then a bunch of other
dermatologists saying people with black
skin still need to wear sunscreen and
they presented both sizes equal but this
is just not how science works it's not a
popular vote again it's about the
consensus of relevant experts and Dr
Adamson is much more relevant than other
dermatologists here he's done that
research and scientific consensus isn't
just like an opinion you need the
scientists to look at and understand the
same data and come to a conclusion that
makes scientific sense the next article
is from the mirror doctor explains what
SPF number on sunscreen really means and
how often to reapply so the first thing
they talk about after all the fluff is
what does SPF mean and they say SPF
refers to the amount of time you can
stay day out in the sun without burning
so with SPF 50 you can stay out in the
sun 50 times longer without burning then
you could have if you didn't have
sunscreen on this myth is really common
and the reason it doesn't work is
because the sun's intensity changes a
lot in SPF testing time works because
the lamp gives out a constant amount of
UV so the UV dose that you're getting
how much is getting into your skin is
directly proportional to how long that
lamp has been on but this doesn't work
in the sun and it definitely doesn't
work with higher SPF in the middle of
the day and summer fair skin burns in
about 10 minutes and so SPF 50 50 times
longer that's 500 minutes which is more
than eight hours your sunscreen is not
going to stay on your skin in an even
film for eight hours you're going to
have to reapply it because it will start
clumping up it will start sweating off
so a better definition is really just
this it's a measure of how well the
sunscreen protects you from getting
burnt there is another myth here which
is that SPF is just to do with the
effect of UVB it isn't there's also some
contribution to burning from UVA if you
blocked out all the UVB and led in all
the UVA you would only get SPF of around
11. on its own it's not the worst myth
but it is linked to another myth which
is mentioned here UVA rays from the Sun
are the ones that cause the DNA damage
it's actually almost completely the
other way around UVB damages DNA
directly DNA will actually absorb UVB
and kind of explode DNA is actually
transparent to UVA UVA will interact
with other things and form free radicals
which then indirectly damage DNA the
reason I think this myth exists is
because we knew about UVB being bad for
ages but we didn't discover uva's damage
for quite a long time so there's this
misconception that UVA is more dangerous
when in reality it's just been
previously underrated now there is one
good thing about UVB and that is it
helps with vitamin D production so this
myth has led to a lot of people asking
why don't we just have UVA sunscreens
that let in all the UVB why don't we
just look for the highest UVA protection
I don't care about SPF but you should
care about SPF because DNA damage again
there's this idea that how much
sunscreen you apply is more important
than SPF I don't really agree I think
they are both important if you have
lower SPF you'll need to apply more and
vice versa but that is really just a
difference of opinion this one is a
common myth I've been seeing in the news
for chemical sunscreens you need to
reapply every two to three hours as it
degrades in sunshine and becomes less
effective mineral sunscreens only need
to be reapplied after swimming charling
off or rubbing it off this is incorrect
and actually quite dangerous the reason
you need to reapply sunscreen is not
because the chemicals are decomposing
it's because the sunscreen film clumps
up on your skin because you have this
film sitting on your skin you have sweat
you have trans epidermal water loss
water is just evaporating out of your
skin you have oil coming out from below
your skin is moving around that does not
want to stay as a nice even complete
film once you have water and oil
punching holes in the film from below
you're not going to have protection in
that Gap if you look on the back of a
mineral sunscreen it will tell you to
reapply every two hours as well as
during these times after swimming
toweling Etc mineral sunscreens can in
fact last less long on the skin because
they are chunky chemical sunscreens can
absorb into those top layers and that
kind of keeps it in place but mineral
sunscreens just sit on top of your skin
in those particles and they tend to move
around and go into furrows so definitely
reapply your mineral sunscreen just like
you would reapply a chemical sunscreen
this bit is correct even if it says the
sunscreen is water resistant you still
need to reapply after swimming that
water resistant rating is based on
people sitting still in a tub of water
you're probably going to be moving
around a lot more in the water which
will make that sunscreen wear off faster
this next bit moisturizer foundation
with SPF isn't sufficient I agree with
the foundation but not with the
moisturizer the way a moisturizer with
SPF and a sunscreen are formulated are
the same whether the product gets cold
or sunscreen or a moisturizer is just
based on marketing not based on what it
does so as long as you apply the same
amount like quarter teaspoon to just
your face you will get the same
protection there are studies that
compared how much of a sunscreen people
applied and how much of an SPF
moisturizer and they found that the SPF
moisturizer wasn't applied as much but
these are generally the SPF moisturizers
that come in jars they're really not
representative of what's on the market
there are a lot of SPF rated
moisturizers which could have very well
just had the word sunscreen on them in
Australia there's a bunch of formulas
that are really similar they have the
same percentages of the active
ingredients and sometimes they're called
SPF moisturizers sometimes they're
called sunscreens so I would judge just
based on texture and not on what word
they used on the packaging this is also
probably not the best order putting
sunscreen and then moisturizer there are
a couple of studies that found that if
you put the moisturizer on after
sunscreen then it kind of works like a
cleansing oil the film just gets messed
up because when you apply a moisturizer
you rub it in general if you've put on
the sunscreen layer you just want to
disturb it as little as possible so
putting the moisturizer on underneath is
a better idea even better would be if
you just use a moisturizing sunscreen or
an SPF moisturizer just have both of
them in the one product our next article
is from Vox it's called seven burning
questions about sunscreens answered the
subtitle is yes you need to wear it and
the start of the article talks about
things like how sunscreen is
non-negotiable regardless of the weather
or your skin type any dermatologist will
say so one thing that's interesting is
that this seems to be only the consensus
for us dermatologists even in Australia
with our level of sun our Official
Guidelines say you only need to wear
sunscreen if the UV index is three or
above now if you're into skincare I
think you should wear it every day
because so many skin concerns are made
worse by UV but from a skin cancer
perspective I really don't think this is
supported by the evidence and again we
have this myth regular sunscreen use can
lower your risk of skin encounters both
among lighter-skinned people who are
more susceptible to skin cancer and
people of color who are more likely to
die from skin cancer due to a delay in
detection again that last bit about
delaying detection is correct but there
is no evidence that regular sunscreen
use will lower the risk of skin cancer
in people with dark skin and this also
extends a bit to other people of color
too the link between sun exposure and
skin cancer is just a lot weaker than
for white people now let's go on to
these actual burning questions again we
see this misconception UVA rays
penetrate the skin more deeply that part
is true but greater contributors to skin
cancer is not it is really well
established that UVB is the greater
contributor this is kind of like
suggesting a myth but they don't really
quite say it UVA rays are aging Rays
there's this common idea that UVA a
stands for aging b stands for burning
but that's not true both of them
contribute to both I already talked
about how short wavelength UVA
contributes to burning UVB also
contributes to aging UV be actually
directly contributes to age spots by
messing up the DNA of melanocytes those
cells that produce melanin at the bottom
of their epidermis but picking a
sunscreen that protects against both UVA
and B is good advice now this is a good
point mineral sunscreens aren't natural
they get processed massively before they
go into a product because you need to
get rid of things like contaminants but
they do have this myth mineral
sunscreens work by creating a barrier on
the skin that reflects UV rays and they
mentioned this related myth chemical
sunscreens get absorbed into the skin
and help create chemical reactions that
lead to repelling the UV rays there's no
chemical reaction involved in absorbing
UV if the chemical sunscreen undergoes a
reaction that is a bad thing it means
it's not photostable it's going to break
down what happens is the electrons
absorb the UV and they get more
energetic but the bonds don't actually
change again if you want more info on
that check out my video on how
sunscreens work there's pros and cons to
each type that is true regardless of
what type of sunscreen you prefer make
sure it's water and sweat resistant I
think water and sweat resistance is good
but it's not really necessary I think
for an everyday sunscreen that you're
wearing to the office water resistant
sunscreens still tend to be pretty
uncomfortable because they form a really
strong film that doesn't move as much
there's no standard for sweat resistance
anywhere so a lot of the time you won't
see this on sunscreens and even if you
do it's hard to tell what it means like
how they tested it unless the company
literally tells you exactly what they
did next they go through some of the
pros and cons of chemical versus mineral
sunscreens and these are pretty good
ones it is mostly about what you prefer
I like that they mentioned fragrance in
the middle of this because that is an
ingredient that some people react to but
it's kind of weird how they kind of say
it is only a concern for chemical
sunscreens later on they do mention
looking for a fragrance-free mineral
sunscreen though so maybe that was just
awkward wording they have this bit on
how much should I spend on sunscreen and
yeah you don't have to buy anything
expensive or fancy this bit with tints
not materially changing the efficacy of
the sunscreen I half agree with this if
you're just talking about SPF then
that's true the SPF is what it says on
the package but that tint comes from
iron oxide which does help with darker
skin if you have pigmentation problems
iron oxide can absorb Blue Light which
can lead to longer lasting pigment
changes how much SPF do I need they have
the SPF definition with time so again
that's not quite correct because the sun
changes and again they have this thing
with how going above SPF 30 is not going
to give you much additional protection
which is not true they say apply
sunscreen 30 minutes before going
outside that's probably Overkill usually
the recommendation is 15 to 20 minutes
and that's just to let it dry down form
a complete film not rub off and also to
make sure you don't go into the Sun and
get a whole bunch of sun exposure before
you get the sunscreen on the best
sunscreen option is one that you'll
readily use that is correct having a
spray is better than nothing but this
bit reapply every two to four hours if
you're in the Sun that is not enough
pretty much every recommendation if
you're spending time Outdoors is reapply
every two hours or perhaps even more
frequently I have seen this myth a few
times times on Australian websites and
it is to do with the four hour water
resistance rating but this is not an
Australian article an Australian four
hour water resistant sunscreased will
still say to reapply every two hours
because of that film wearing off
honestly I think they should change that
water resistance rating to a different
name for four hours it's kind of
misleading wear sunscreen on your face
and neck every day as UV rays can
penetrate windows in your home and car I
don't think this is really necessary it
depends on what your home is like I have
a video on working out whether or not
you need to wear indoor sunscreen in the
car I think you do because you have so
much window space but in your home if
you're not sitting directly in the sun
if you're quite far away from the window
you probably don't need sunscreen now
this bit French and Korean sunscreens
versus American ones there is this idea
I see a lot online still which is Korean
sunscreens are less reliable than ones
from the US and I completely disagree
the article says a few years ago there
were some Korean sunscreens that a
company had tested by an independent
laboratory and it did not perform up to
the label claim of the SPF this issue is
really not limited to Korea I've talked
about it before in another video there
are lots of consumer magazines that do
independent SPF testing on sunscreens
they've purchased and published the
results Consumer Reports Which choice
consumer NZ and every year there are a
bunch that fail part of this is because
SPF testing is a biological test and
there is usually more variation with
that so there's always been lots of
variation between different SPF testing
Labs it depends on the country what
sorts of people are coming in and
getting their skin tested who's looking
at when the skin goes pink but some of
them do fall short by quite a lot and it
does feel weird to single our career
when the biggest cause of these fails is
probably the us the biggest sunscreen
testing Scandal that's ever happened was
with AMA Laboratories in the US it's on
the FDA website this lab was essentially
committing fraud for 30 years from 1987
until 2017. for SPF testing you need to
have a certain number of people you're
testing on and they just pretended they
had more people they just like made up
numbers so this means they could really
speed up testing and they could also
charge a lot less so lots and lots of
Brands used them there's now even a
special note in the Australian
regulations where it says if you got
your sunscreens tested by this lab you
need to have new tests done by some date
with the Korean sunscreens Adele Menard
has a video on that the issue seems to
be they change from a tinted sunscreen
to untinted without retesting it and
this is allowed in a lot of places
around the world in Korea this loophole
seems to be fixed now and this is one
really good thing about Korean
Regulators they are very quick to deal
with problems so I don't think this
problem is really relevant to Korean
sunscreens anymore but sunscreens do
fail testing all the time including from
the brands mentioned here and here are
my rankings the longer the article the
more myths so I also calculated it as
words per myth like a measurement of
Miss sparseness and the longer articles
ended up doing better maybe because they
were more padded out I also counted
which myths came not the most no
surprise our grandpa myth topped it I
made this sunscreen myth bingo card a
while back the stuff on the right is
mostly crunchy social media myths so I
didn't really expect to do that well
there but the ones on the left are the
ones I've seen from more trusted sources
Jason hit rate I did not expect these
two myths to come up as much as they did
so overall the myths in these articles
aren't that bad but it is really
frustrating to see these come up again
year after year and still not get
corrected it'll be really nice to see a
better hit rate over the years maybe
I'll just repeat this exercise every
year I did have a couple of other
articles from Bloomberg and Reader's
Digest which had really fear-mongering
myths about the toxic effects of
sunscreen which I couldn't really fit
into this video because I would have to
go into a lot more detail I'll probably
talk about those soon but yeah I hope
you found this interesting in the
meantime the most important things for
finding a sunscreen look for a sunscreen
that's protective enough for whatever
activity you're doing these are the
three labels you're looking for if
you're doing something really sweet
ready then go for the Maxima for all of
these second thing you're looking for is
the sunscreen that you enjoy enough to
wear every day this includes things like
texture whether it irritates your skin
even whether or not it fits in your
budget if you have a sunscreen that's
really expensive that you skimp on that
is not good value if you have a
sunscreen that was really cheap that you
don't enjoy and you never use that it's
also not good value see you next time
there is a 50 50 chance it'll be about
sunscreen